okay hi everyone I'll get started the last class okay um yeah well welcome congratulations and thank you to making it to the um last real lecture of cs224n yeah so so this is the plan for today um the lecture's titled NLP Linguistics and philosophy which I took as meaning that I could talk about anything I wanted to um and so that is what I'm going to do um so this is sort of this um what we're going to go through talk a bit about the major ideas of Cs 24n and open problems um some of
the more foundational questions of where are we with llm symbolic versus neural systems meaning and Linguistics and NLP and then I'll close with um some slides on the future risks of AI in the world okay so here is an attempt to sort of lay out the most major things that we looked at in cs224n um we started with word vectors then we developed the idea of neural NP systems we expanded from a simple feed forward Network into doing sequence models language models rnns lstms and then we introduced this powerful new
model that's been very influential the Transformer and then we built from there to the kind of um it's not exactly an architecture but model that's been built up in recent years to produce high performance NLP systems where we're first doing pre-training and then a uh post-training phase of various techniques that we talked about to produce um these General Foundation models that understand language so well and then we went on from there and talked about various particular topics
like benchmarking and reasoning so a few of the major ideas that we looked at were um this idea that you could get a long way by having dense representations those are our hidden representations in new networks and then looking at distributional semantics representing words by their context um first slogan of you shall know a word by the company it keeps and I'll come back to that a bit later and talking about um ideas of meaning but you know that's essentially been the idea that has driven most of
the successful ideas of modern NLP whether it's the earli statistical NLP phase or more modern neural NLP phase and in this world we start instantiating that as um these models of word vectors but the same contextual idea is then used in all the models up through Transformers we looked at both the challenges and opportunities um of training large deep newal networks and how gradually people developed ideas and tricks such as having residual connections which made it much more possible and stable to do
successfully um which took us from a place where a lot of this seemed black magic that was hard to get right to people being able to very reliably train high performance Transformer models um we talked about sequence models what's good about them and some of their problems and how those problems have been addressed in large measure by adopting this different architecture of Transformers which give a form of parallelization and then we moved into the modern form of pre-training by language modeling where language
modeling seems a simple thing predicting words in context but it emerges as what we think of as a universal pre-training task that all kinds of both linguistic and World Knowledge help you to do this task of predicting words better and so this is ended up as just a general method um to produce the kind of um powerful knowledgeable models that we have today and up until now there's been this amazing property that we see this empirical fact that we seem to just get this um basically well not basically
it's extremely linear improvements of performance as we continue to scale data and compute and model model size up by orders of magnitude um that doesn't mean that all problems in NLP are solved um there are lots of things that people um still work on and see opportunities to try and make things better and a few of these um are mentioned on the next few slides um so there's a real question of how much um these models are good at actually learning to be able to do things generally rather than just being very
good at memorization um that a lot of the benefits of what we're getting from these large pre-trained language models is that they've seen a huge amount of stuff and therefore they know everything they've seen every pattern before and they know how to use things I've occasionally use the analogy that um large language models are sort of like a talking and encyclopedia that they're really in many ways more like a huge knowledge store than necessarily something that is intelligent in the
sense of being able to work out how to solve new problems and generalize as human beings do a kind of interesting fact actually is that in some ways Transformer models are actually worse at generalizing than the older lstms that preceded them so here's just you know one little graph I'm not going to spend a lot of time on but this was looking at data that's being generated by a finite autometer and then trying to learn it from a limited amount of data um with either an lstm or a Transformer and the
observation is that you know at the scales that they're working even having seen quite limited exemplification the lstm is basically sealing the entire of this graph right it's just at the one line um because it generalizes in good ways because of its lstm architecture um whereas the Transformer needs to see a ton more data before it actually learns the patterns well and so if we think of one of the Prime attributes of human intelligence is actually we're amazing at figuring out and learning things from very
limited exposure right you know there's something that you don't know how to do and a friend shows you once um what you do to make it work and by and large you know you'll improve a few times with practice but you can learn effectively new skills from these kind of single shot examples um and that's not always what we seem to be seeing in our models um there's a lot of interest in what's going on inside newal networks that a lot of the time newal networks still appear as blackboxes where we have no
real idea of how they're doing what they're doing and as perhaps for your final projects the main thing you're doing is measuring um the final performance number and seeing if it goes up or not um so there's a lot of interest in better understanding what do they learn how did they learn it why do they succeed and fail and a lot of that work is star to look more closely into what's happening inside new network computations um there is some work of that sort that actually goes back quite
a fair way so here's um an old blog post by Andre Kathy while he's a grad student here in 2016 and he he was looking at lstms and how did they learn and he found that one of the neurons in an lstm cell was effectively sort of measuring position along a line of text and as the line of text got long its sort of value started to change because the model was learning that there was sort of a line length of this text and that the line was likely to be ending at that point and in recent times there started to be with
Transformers as well a lot of work looking at mechanistic interpretability or causal abstraction trying to understand the internals of models um a problem that's far from solved and in many respects probably unsolvable is the multilingual question of dealing with all the other languages of the world um that you do have to keep in your head that whatever you see for English um it's worse for every other language um and what they're getting out of modern language models now you know there is a good news story here I don't
want to claim that everything is terrible so in this graph which is kind of small um the blue line was the performance of GPT 3.5 English and then all of the the green um bars are then the performance of GPT 4 and so you know there's a genuine good news story here which is look not just for English but for a lot of other languages for Greek lvan um Arabic Turkish um all of them in GP 4 better than English was in gpt3 3.5 so you know that's the good news argument um that um you know building these
models big is in some sense raising all boats but you know these are still all huge languages and you know things are starting to drop off at the bottom of this table um for um languages where the performance is worse than than English and GPT 3.5 but even for those languages they're they're languages for which much less written data is available but they're still large languages so the ones at the three at the bottom are actually all Indian languages they're Punjabi morati and telu um and which are
languages that are each spoken by millions of people they're not small languages um so the real question is what happens when you actually get to the small resource languages so the vast majority of languages around the world don't have millions of speakers they vary from having hundreds of speakers to hundreds of thousands of speakers and there are thousands of such languages a lot of those languages are primarily oral and have very limited amounts of um written text now some of those languages
are likely or many of those languages are likely to go extinct um in the coming decades um but many of those language communities would like to preserve their languages and it's very unclear how the kind of language technologies that we've been talking about in the later parts of um the course can be extended to those languages because there just isn't sufficient data to build the kind of models that we've been looking at so I imagine you've gotten some idea in this course of how evaluation is a
huge part of what we do that effectively a lot of the way that progress is being driven is by defining evaluations of what models should be able to achieve and then people working um to measure um systems and improve systems so they do better on what we see as good language other understanding or other properties um one of the concerns that many people have about what's happened with the large recent um Clos models from large companies is a concern that all of the benchmarks are being sullied and not to
be trusted um so here's um one example um that comes from a tweet of Horus Hurst um and he's noting I suspect gp4s performance is influenced by data contamination at least on code forces one of the coding benchmarks of the easiest problems on Co code forces it solved 10 out of 10 pre 2021 problems but zero out of 10 recent problems this strongly points to contamination and the worry is that every time you're seeing these fantastic results of how well the latest best language model is performing
that at this point so much data is on the web that gets included um in the pre-training data for these large language models that essentially they're memorizing at least a good share of the questions that are appearing in these challenges so they're not actually solving them in a fair way as an independent test set at all they're just memorizing them and so there are sort of issues then as to you know what kind of Thoroughly hidden test sets we can have or dynamic evaluation mechanisms so we
can actually have Benchmark Integrity another huge area the number of us involved in Stanford elsewhere is making NLP work in different technical domains so domains including biomedical or clinical medical NLP have a lot of differences of vocabulary um and usage they have a lot of potential good uses but they also have a lot of potential risks of doing harm if the language understanding is incomplete I myself have been more involved um doing things in the legal NLP um working with other people at the reg lab with danho in
building Foundation models for law um and there are all kinds of ways again in which um this kind of Technology could be really useful right the biggest problem in most countries it's bad in the United States but it's way worse in a place like India is that most people can't get access to the kind of legal help that they need to solve their problems because of the cost of it and the lack of um trained lawyers so if more could be done to be able to help people via um NLP tools you know in
principle that would be great but in practice um the tools still don't have good enough language understanding um so um in the reg lab there's a just completed study out at the moment looking at um legal NLP systems and we were finding that the hallucination rate the rate in which there was madeup stuff in their legal AR answers was effectively for one question in six which isn't a very good accuracy rate if you're someone who's wanting to rely on these systems um for legal advice um there are lots of things also
to work out dealing with the social and cultural aspects of NLP NLP systems remain very biased against various cultures and religions um they they have certain social norms you could say that they pick up from somewhere but those social norms are very biased it's against certain groups and um related to um there being small languages that I mentioned before that there are lots of issues with underrepresented groups in having the kind of NLP that they'd like to have okay so um that's sort of the
summary of that bit so for the next bit I thought I'd just sort of give one more bit of perspective on where are we um with um the best um language models like gp4 I mean I think it's really interesting at this moment of where we are CU you know on the one hand the performance of these models is just amazing and you know even as someone who works in NLP and has worked in it for many many years now I mean you know I can tell a a sort of story that these models you know that we do this training
to predict the next word and it's conditioning on a lot of text and it knows about things and it does but you know in some sense these things still seem like magic right it's just kind of hard to believe how this could possibly work so in this example I asked chat GPT 40 I did that this this morning I asked and um to write a sonnet explaining the Transformer neet architecture in which every line begins with the letter t um and it sort of still frankly blows my mind and I don't actually feel I can
really explain even to myself in a way that's convincing how this large Transformer is able to take all its pre-training text and reading that instruction um and as a next tokken prediction machine it successfully produces something that is a Sonet and every line begins with the letter T I hope you remember from your high school English classes sonnets are meant to have AB um rhyming um it's a little bit imperfect here net set some people will complain about that but it's basically a rhyme
behold unfold grasp clasp right so it's basically doing the writing rhyming right and um the lines are meant to be an i Amic pentameter and it's basically produced lines and I Amic pentameter to delve into the world of neural Nets you know I Amic pentam um yeah it's incredible so here's um it's Sonet it came up with to delve into the world of neural Nets Transformers Rise a Marvel to behold through layers deep the networks path is set to learn from data patterns to unfold the tokens feed into
attentions grasp to weigh their import context to a line the query's keys and values in a clasp to process sequences with power fine through heads of many multifaceted site to parallelize capturing the span transforming each a matrix math Delight to synthesize with elegance and plan the models might in every task it shows to turn raw data into wisdom's Pros now now you you could object um that I'm not sure this exactly explained the transform new net architecture um it's a little bit
abstract I'll give it that but you know in another sense it did it did in one place or another evoke quite a bit of stuff about Transformers with queries keys and values and multiheaded stuff parallelized with Matrix math and whatever else um yeah still still kind of blows my mind how well that works and you know indeed um as natural language understanding and sort of world understanding devices I mean these devices have clearly crossed the threshold in which they're very usable in many contexts so here's
there's now started to be some fairly good studies um that have been done on you know how much value people can get out of using llms like um gp4 um so this um study by dequa and a whole lot of colle including Ethan mik um they took a bunch of Consultants from the Boston Consulting Group and so you know what that's like that means you know 23 year olds graduating from universities like this one but more on the East Coast um they become you know Boston Consultants you know not exactly um dummies um and so they they found in
this study so you know controlled task um there are there actually so three groups but the big contrast is that you know two of the groups were using gp4 to do Consulting tasks and one of the groups wasn't using um gp4 to do tasks the difference between the two that were was one of them was giving given more training on how to use gp4 but that didn't seem to make much of a difference um but their result was um that the groups using gp4 um in their study completed 12% more tasks on average they did the task 25%
more com quickly and um the results were judged 40% higher quality than those not using AI which I think is a pretty um stunning success of how um gp4 or similar llms are good enough to actually help people get real work done you know with whatever asteris you want to put about the quality of Management Consultant work in various instances um yeah I mean an interesting result is that you know using these llms seem to be a big leveler and actually you see exactly the same thing for people using um coding llms that they're a huge
assistance for people whose own skills are weaker and they're much less of an assistance for people whose own skills are strong okay so that's the good news story but you know if on the other hand you're more like the good news story for human beings um here's a study um that goes in the other direction can gp4 write fiction that matches the quality of New Yorker fiction writers um and the result of that study was not even close um that gp4 was measured as 3 to 10 times worse at creative writing than a
New Yorker fiction writer so there's still hope for human beings hang on there um and so you know I think that's kind of the you know the jewel screen picture that we have at the moment then in some ways these things are great and useful in other ways um they're not so great and I think that's something um that we're still sort of going to be um seeing playing out um in the future years I think um living in Silicon Valley um we see a lot of the positive hype so if you just want to um see a
little bit of the negative on the other side um late last year there was uh peace in the financial times um which was titled generative AI hyly intelligent um and I won't read all of this um but basically they were a wanting to express um considerable um skepticism of the current AI boom investors should keep their heads expectations for generative AI are running way ahead of the limitations that apply to it as investment in generative AI grows so does pressure to create new use cases by 2027 IDC thinks
Enterprise spending on generative AI will reach 143 billion up from 16 billion this year so 10 times up open AI hopes for more funding to pursue humanlike AI it is worth remembering that when examining alman's plan for super intelligence models predict they do not comprehend that limitation cast out on AI achieving even humanlike intelligence um and then they sort of start talking about some the problems um with you know limited gains for low skilled workers inaccuracies in the work they produc um and suggests that the
limitations will become more obvious as generative AI tools roll out that will put pressure on providers to address costs AI could add 4 trillion to profits says McKenzie but pricing Clarity is lacking without it companies cannot predict what Financial gains AI can accomplish and AI cannot predict that either okay um that's that topic I'm chugging through my topics um the next topic is I wanted to return and say a bit more about symbolic methods that dominated AI from the 60s until about
2010 versus um what I termed here is cybernetics because the original alternative going back to the 50s and 60s um was called cybernetics and in a very real sense neural networks is a continuation of the cybernetics tradition rather than the AI tradition that started in the 50s and 60s um in this context um Stanford is the home of the symbolic systems program um so at the moment um we are unique in having a symbolic systems program um so the name symbolic systems came about because at the time it was started um so I guess
philosophy was an active part of the symbolic systems program and John barwise um shown in this picture he actually died young so he he actually died in 2000 um John barwise um had um a very strong belief um that you me to be um dealing with meaning in the world and the connection between people's thinking in the world and so he um refused to allow the program to be called cognitive science as it's called at most other places and it ended up being called symbolic systems um now at one point
there were two universities that had symbolic systems CU John barise actually moved away from Stanford and went to Indiana which is where he originally was from um and so Indiana also had a symbolic systems program for a number of years but they've actually changed Theirs to cognitive science now since he died so we are unique in having symbolic systems and so the idea of symbolic systems this is sort of what's on the website website with a bit of interpretation right so symbolic system
studies systems are meaningful symbols that represent the world about us like human languages Logics and programming languages and the systems that work with these symbols like brains computers and complex social systems contrasting that to the sort of typical view of cognitive science which is focusing on the mind and intelligence as a naturally occurring phenomenon um symbolic systems gives equal Focus to human constructed systems that use symbols to communicate and to represent information right so um in AI terms um you know AI
as a field and the name AI um arose um around arguing for a symbolic approach right that John um John McCarthy who's the color photo there and who um founded Stanford's artificial intelligence um and the St the original famous Stanford AI lab so John McCarthy came up with the name artificial intelligence and he very ex very explicitly chose a new name to um disassociate what he was doing um from the cybernetics approach um which had been pursued by people including um Norbert weer um at MIT who's shown on
the right side um so Marvin miny the Teeny um photo down here um sort of founded um artificial intelligence at MIT um McCarthy worked with him for a few years and then McCarthy came to Stanford um and two of the other most prominent early AI people new and Simon who were at CMU and the other two people on the right side and so in particular um new and Simon um develop well actually no let me say a sentence first yeah so I mean McCarthy's own background was a mathematician and logician right so that he wanted to
construct uh an artificial intelligence that looked like math and logic effectively right and that sort of was AI as a symbolic system and that was developed as a position in the philosophy of artificial intelligence by new and Simon and so they developed what they called the physical symbol system hypothesis um so that said a phys iCal symbol system has the necessary and sufficient means for General intelligent action and so you know that's a super strong claim it's not only claiming that
um having a symbol system allows you to produce artificial general intelligence but through um the necessary Clause that you can't have artificial general intelligence without having a symbol system um so that was sort of um the basis of um classical AI right um so um and that kind of contrasts a bit with the you know so cybernetics you know had its origins in sort of control and communication so it's much nearer to sort of an electrical engineering kind of background um and was wanting to sort
of um unify ideas of control and communication between animals um maybe perhaps more than humans and machines um yeah so I mean you know um sort of in yeah so cybernetics comes from a Greek word um kubernetes which is sort of interesting all the uses it has so it's exactly the same route that occurs both in kubernetes if you're are familiar with that as you know distributed containers on Modern systems but also it's actually the same route that the word government comes from um course
it's a control system as well um yeah um so under the cybernetics tradition was when newal Nets first started being explored um the very earliest neuron Nets um the most famous ones are Frank Rosen blats which were used for vision the newal net was actually wired um to say just a teeny bit about this in case you think that AI hype is only a thing of the 2020s there was just as much AI hype in the 1950s when Rosen blat um unveiled his perceptron um so in the New York Times article about it new Navy device learns
by doing psychologist shows embryo of computer design to read and grow wiser the Navy revealed the embryo of an of an electronic computer today that it expects will be able to walk talk see write reproduce itself and be conscious of its existence um and this hype is all the more incredible when you get to the um later paragraph of the article and you find out what the demonstration was actually of and the demonstration that people were shown um was um that this device learned to differentiate between right arrow and
left arrow pictures after 50 [Laughter] exposures but there you go okay um yeah so what what do we make of this in the case of NLP and language and you know the position I would like to suggest is you know there's just no doubt um that language is a Sy symbolic system right that humans developed language as a symbolic system it's perhaps most obvious um that if you think about it in writing we have symbols of the letters and words that we use but even if there's no writing and you know the majority of human language
use over time has been verbal human language use that even though the substrate it's carried on where the sound waves or in sign languages movements of hands even though that's a continuous substrate the structure of human languages is a symbol system we have symbols which are the sounds of human languages for cat we have a c an at and a t those are symbols and they're recognized in a symbolic Way by language users and indeed um the all the pioneering work and categorical perception in cognitive psychology is
done with um the sounds of human languages um the phones as linguists call them so spoken language also has a symbolic structure but you know going against new and Simon the fact that humans use a symbol system for communication doesn't mean that the process of the symbols the human brain has to be a physical symbol system and so similarly we don't have to design NLP our computer processors as physical symbol systems either um the brain is you know clearly much more like a newal network model um and probably newal
models will scale better and capture language processing better than something that is a symbolic processor um in the same way I mean that sort of leaves behind the question of well why did humans come up with a symbol system for communication I mean after all you know we could have just sort of hummed at different frequencies and that could have been used as our system of communication I mean I think the dominant idea which seems reasonable to me but who knows is that um having a symbolic system gives signaling
reliability right that if you have discrete Target points that are separated then that gives you an ability um when there's degradation of the signal to recover it well um yeah so where does that leave Linguistics which is mainly um been developed in terms of um describing a symbolic system I think the right way to think about it as Linguistics is good for giving us questions Concepts and distinctions when thinking about language acquisition processing and understanding and indeed one of the
interesting things that's come about is that sort of as um NLP and AI have been developed further and as able to do a lot of low-level stuff that there's actually the sort of higher level Concepts that linguists often talk about a lot things like compositionality and systematic generalization which I'll come back to in a few minutes um the mapping of stable meanings for symbols the reference of um linguistic expressions in the world that they get talked about more and more in artificial
intelligence context building neural systems and I mean I think one way to think about is that you know a lot of the early neural netw work um of um most notably visual processing but also other kinds of sensory stuff like sounds I mean doing that is sort of what gets you to insect level intelligence and if you want to get higher up the chain than insect level intelligence then a lot of the kind of questions and properties of linguistic systems become increasingly relevant um at a slightly more prosaic
level um that I don't think one necessarily wants to believe all the F details of different um linguistic theories but you know for how human languages are structured and how they behave I think yeah most of our broad understanding of linguistics is right and so therefore when we're thinking about NP systems and we're thinking about you know understanding how they behave wanting to know whether they have certain properties thinking up ways to evaluate them a lot of that is done in terms of linguistic understand standing
wanting to see whether they capture facts about sentence structure discourse structure semantic properties like natural language inference um whether you can do things like bridging and AFA which I did not cover this year's class because we skipped the co- reference lecture when we slice one lecture off the class metaphors presuppositions all of these things are linguistic Notions that we try and get our NLP models to capture so I just want to say a couple more remarks um about you know the role
of human language in human intelligence I think this is kind of interesting um so an interesting person in the history of linguistics um is this guy vilhelm Von Hot um who is um a prominent German academic um so um so really the American education system um was borrowed from Germany right so up until the second world war the preeminent place of Science and learning was Germany and Germany um essentially via V Von humber's work developed the idea of having graduate education and the US copied graduate education from Germany
and started um doing its own but you know in in that context it was still the case that um for people in the United United States prior to the 1930s that generally people would go to Germany um to finish their education either to get their PHD or to do a postdoc or something like that right so you know if you uh Trace back my own academic tree or most other academic trees of people who got phds in the US they actually go back a few generations and then they go back to Germany um so uh we don't think of that as much in the
modern world yeah so um hbal was influential and developing the university system um but he also um worked a lot on um language and I he's someone that um Chomsky always cites um because he's known for this famous statement about that human language must make infinite use of finite means so the fact that we have a limited um Supply of words and sentence structures but out of those we can recursively build up an infinite number of sentences and that's in chomsky's view supporting the kind of
um symbolic structured view of language that he's been advocating but I think there's sort of another interesting take of Von Holts which um we can argue whether it's um right or not but I think is kind of interesting and one of the things he want wants to stress is that language isn't just something um used for the purpose of communication um that he um I should actually introduce something here so um so caraman and tersi are two well-known cognitive psychologists and they introduced this idea that there are
two kinds of thinking system one cognition and system 2 cognition and system one is the kind of subconscious thinking that you're not really thinking of just we process stuff when it comes into our heads whether visual signals or um speech and system 2 Thinking is um the conscious let me think about this and try and figure out what's going on I'm solving a math problem style of thinking and um you know I think you can see in Von Holt's writings essentially the same kind of distinction between
system 1 and system 2 cognition although he refers to system one cognition as a of the spirit um and system to cognition as thinking um yeah and so basically he argues for a version of the philos philosophical position of the language of thought of suggesting that effective system to thinking um requires extension of the Mind through the symbols of language um and so he argued that having language is absolutely a necessary foundation for the progress of the human mind and I think that's actually an
interesting perspective which I have some sympathy with I mean you know obviously we can think without language you know we can feel afraid we can think visually and about how things that fit together but I think it's fairly plausible that for the sort of more abstract larger scale thinking that humans engage in and has led them to sort of higher levels of thought than a chimpanzee gets to that language gives a scaffolding Inside the Mind that makes that possible another version of that um is from the philosopher Daniel dennet
who just actually died a couple of months ago um so dennet wrote this book um called from bacteria to bark and back and the main thing this book was about was the origin of human consciousness and I'm not going to talk about human consciousness um today um but um he introduced this model of four grades of progressively more competent intelligences um and so the four levels um he outlined was that the bottom one was dar wian so darwinian intelligence was something that was predesigned and fixed it doesn't improve during its
lifetime Improvement only happens um by Evolution through genetic selection um so things like bacteria and viruses are darwinian intelligences so then after that was scaran intelligences and so they improve Behavior by learning to respond on to reinforcement um so something like a lizard um or you know perhaps a dog we could um argue about how intelligent dogs are um has um scaran intelligence and so then the third level up um paparian intelligence is things that learn models of the environment so they
can improve performance by thinking through plans and then executing them and seeing how they behave so in a computational sense paparian intelligence kind of means that you can do modelbased reinforcement learning um and so um primates like chimpanzees can definitely um do the kind of planning and modelbased um reinforcement learning that gives you a preparan intelligence but actually a lot of recent evidence shows that a lot of simp simpler creatures can also do it um so I'm not sure the facts here so all
these studies you see are about um crows from um the South Pacific Australia and Fiji and places like that so I'm not sure if Northern Hemisphere crows are Dumber but at least southern hemisphere crows um can learn plans so that they can do multi-stage planning to work out ways to get a piece of meat that's down a Hole by learning to pick up a stick and poke it in and um so you know that even crows can be paparian intelligences um but what Dennis suggests is that there's a stage Beyond um paparian
intelligence which he calls Gregorian intelligence and the idea of Gregorian intelligence is that you can build Thinking Tools which allow you to do a higher level of control of mental searches and So He suggests that you know things like well mathematics is a thinking tool but well also democracy is a thinking tool but nevertheless out of the space of Thinking Tools um that human language is the preminent thinking tool that we have and So He suggests that you know the only biolog iCal example we have of a Gregorian
intelligence um as human beings and so that I I think in that kind of sense you can say that there's a very important role for language okay two parts to go in my um summary okay so the next one is what kind of semantic should we use for language um and so this is getting back to the question I mentioned for word vectors and this is kind of interesting so the semantics that's been dominant in philosophy of language or in linguistic semantics is a notion of model theoretic semantics where the meaning of words is
their denotation what they represent in the world I mentioned this I think in a early lecture right so that if you have a word like computer the meaning of computer is the set of computers this one that one that one all the other computers are out right so it's denotational relationship between a word and its denotation in the world or in a model of the world and that was the um notion that was used in most of the history of AI for doing symbolic Ai and that then contrasts with this sort of
distributional semantics that the meaning of a word is understanding the context in which it's used which is effectively what we're using um for our neural models yeah so if if you look at the traditional view of understand interpreting the meaning of human language um and this is what you'll have seen if you did an intro logic class at some point right that we have a sentence the red apple is on the table and you get to write in some logical representation first order predicate calculus or whatever this one's a bit
different to allow in thus where normally for first order predal calculus you only do um for all and if there exists but you have a a sort of a formal logic and you know in the early week in weeks one and two of the logic class you have some English sentences for which you translate into formal logic and then after that um you forget about human languages and you just sort of start proving stuff about formal logical systems um and so to some extent what you get a philosophy class um represents the tradition of Alfred tasi um so taski
believed that you couldn't talk about meaning in terms of talking about human languages because human languages were quot quote impossibly incoherent um yeah and so um from about the sort of 1940s until um 1980 you know tasy was the preeminent legis um in the US um he was in Berkeley um and so that was very much um the view of the logicians of the world but during that period one of his students um was this guy Richard montigue so um Richard montigue sort of rebelled against that picture um saying
I reject the contention that an important theoretical difference exists between formal and natural languages and so he then set about um showing that well you could start building up a formal semantics for describing the meaning of natural language sentences and so Richard monu's work became the foundation of the work that's used in um semantics in linguistics as well for anyone who's done 1 Ling 130 or 230 um the picture you saw is sort of a montigue picture of um semantics and so that was the semantics that
was um taken over and essentially used as the model of doing natural language understanding for most of the history of NLP you know roughly 1960 to 2015 17 you know and so the picture essentially was that if we wanted to have a sentence that we interpreted like the red apple is on the table what we would do is we'd first produce a syntactic structure for the sentence so we would pause it um and then using ideas roughly along the lines that montue suggested we would construct its meaning by looking up meanings of words
in a lexicon and then using the compositionality of human languages to work out the meanings of progressively larger phrases and clauses in terms of the meanings of those words and the way that they are combined slightly reminiscent of my discussion of tree structures to meanings in the last lecture I gave and so you would build up um a meaning representation of a sentence and so this could then give you a semantic meaning of a sentence that you could use in a system um this is approximately a slide except titled that
I actually used to use in cs224n um in the 2000s decade right so we have a we have um or part of a sentence um I get oh no it's a whole sentence here it is how many red cars what can I get this sentence I think there's a sentence here how many oh how many red cars in Palo Alo does Kathy like how many red cars in pal does Kathy like and sorry yeah the cars sorry got hidden underneath here um yeah so we have a sentence we pass it we look up meanings of words in a lexicon we start composing them up um we get a semantic
form for the whole sentence which we can then convert into SQL and we can run against a database and we can get the answer and this was a in outline the kind of technology that was widely used for natural language understanding systems that were built anywhere from the 1960s to the 2s and1s and you know in particular um they were used not only in a purely kind of rule based grammar and lexicon way this same basic technology was incorporated into a machine learning context where your goal was to start to learn various of these
parts you could not only learn the paraa but you could also um learn semantic meanings of words and learn composition rules and so the Acme of that work was then what was called semantic paring that was pioneered by Luke zettel moer and Mike Collins in the 2000th decade and then taken up by others including um Percy leang so person's PhD thesis but also actually his early work at Stanford before he was convinced to do neural networks um was doing semantic paing um work um so you know these systems could
actually work and were used in limited domains but they're always extremely brittle um and yeah the interesting thing is sort of what of humans I mean there is you know some evidence that humans do something like this that they um work out the structure of sentences and compute um meanings um in a a bottom up mostly projective way you know there's a lot of controversy to exactly how human understanding of sentences still works but you know there are certainly people have argued in support
of human brains doing something similar um that's obviously not what we're getting with current day Transformers and so you know the question is do our current day um neural language models provide suitable meaning functions and that's you know a complex question CU you know in many ways yeah they seem to they do an amazing job at understanding whatever sentences you put into them but there's still some genuine concerns as to whether they are making shortcuts or work to a certain extent and don't actually have
the same kind of compositional understanding with systematic generalization that human beings do okay um so that's the traditional denotational semantics View and that contrasts um with the kind of use theory of meaning and in the first or second lecture and at the beginning of this one I attributed that to the British linguist Jr fth you shall know a word by the company at kees but it's not only a position of f it's also been a minority position of philosophers in particular it was Advanced by viken Stein and his
later work and his work philosophical invest vation so in that work he writes when I talk about language words sentences Etc I must speak the language of every day is this language somehow too coarse and material for what we want to say then how is another one to be constructed and how strange that we should be able to do anything at all with the one we we have um philosophical investigations is written in this sort of vaguely poetical literary style but the point of it is meant to be saying look these logician people are
claiming you can't use natural langu human languages to express meaning and you have to translate into this um symbol system but isn't that a weird concept that one symbol system is no good but this other symbol system somehow fixes things um and then about denotational semantics he writes you say the point isn't the word but it's meaning and you think of the meaning as a thing of the same kind as the word they also different from the word he the word there the meaning so that's the
symbol and its denotation the money and the cow that you can buy with it um but contrast money in its use and he goes on from there to argue for the kind of you know the meaning of money is the way that money can be used in the world the meaning of money isn't pointing at pieces of money okay so this this is what's referred to as a use theory of meaning and so the question is is that a good theory of meaning so some people just don't accept um this kind of distributional semantic use theories of meaning um as a theory
of meaning or semantics most prominently in recent NLP work that's the position of Bender and cola that they just take as axiomatic the only thing that counts as having a meaning is that you got form over here and meaning over there um but I think that that's too narrow I think we have to argue that meaning arises from connect meaning of words arises from connecting words to other things and although in some sense you could say connecting um words to things in the real world is privileged it's not
the only way that you can ground meanings you can have meanings in a virtual world but you can also have meanings by connecting one word to other things in human language and the other thing that I think you need to say is you know meaning isn't a sort of a zero1 thing that you know the denotation of a word or you don't I think meaning is a gradient thing and you can understand meanings of words and phrases either more or less and so this is an example I gave in a piece that I wrote a couple of
years ago okay what is the um meaning of the word Shai um well maybe a few of you know it but um if you don't well what could I do um well you know if you'd seen or held one you'd have classic grounded meaning um know something about the denotation um well if that's not the case well you know I could at least show you picture of one here's a picture of one so that gives you some information about what a Shai is but you know is that the only thing I can do I mean suppose well sorry I left out a bullet
point you know so this gives you a partial meaning of a Shai but surely you have a richer meaning if you'd heard one being played um and well is showing you a picture of one the only thing I can do um suppose you'd never you know seen felt or heard one but you know I told you it's a traditional Indian instrument a bit like an OBO well I think you understand something about the meaning of the word at that point um that you know it's sort of connected to India it's a wind instrument using reads
that's used for playing music you know I could tell you some other things about it I could say it has whole sort of like a recorder but has multiple reads and a flared end more like an OBO um then maybe you know a bit more about a shenai even though you've never seen one um and um if you then extend to what we do more in um our sort of Corpus based linguistic learning you know you could imagine it's not that I tried to Define one for you instead I've just shown you a textual use example so here or several
of those so here's one textual use example from a week before Shai players sat in bamboo ma CH at the entrance to the house playing their pipes bash Babu disliked the Shai's whale but was determined to fulfill every conventional expectation the Grooms family might have um so if that's all you know about a Shai you know in some ways you understand less of the mean meaning of the word than if you'd seen one but actually in other ways you understand more of the meaning of the word than if you just seen one
because you know from that one textual example you know some things you um have heard a characterization of the sound as wailing um and um you know that it's connected with weddings which you don't get from just having um held or looked at one or even you know having had someone stand in front of you and play it and you know that's an important part of the meaning of aai to um people and so that's the sense in which I think so meaning comes from various kinds of connections okay last topic our AI
future um yeah so there are different senses of our AI future and lots of things um that can we can be worried about one thing we can be worried about is whether we're all going to lose our jobs um interesting question uh here's a newspaper article from The New York Times March of the machine makes Idle Hands prevalence of unemployment with greatly increased industrial output points to the influence of Labor saving devices as an underlying cause um this was published in the New York Times in
1928 um but you know it turns out that quite quite a few people like labor saving machines like washing machines and dishwashers and um sewing machines lots of useful labor saving machines um and well you know this was published in 1928 just before um you know at a time when a small group of immensely powerful and rich men dominated the United States um just before the Great Depression um but what happened in the decades after that um greatly changed policies in the United States led to Boom years that
distributed um wealth and work much more evenly across the country and the country boomed you know here's another one in the past new Industries hired far more people than those they put out of business but this is this is not true of many today's new Industries today's new Industries have comparatively few jobs for the unskilled or semiskilled just the class of workers whose jobs are being eliminated by automation you know this was um Time magazine in 1961 um so this is a longstanding um
fear which at least so far has not been realized you know here we are um in which a country in which not everyone might have the work that they wish they had but that overall almost everybody has a job and many people are working a lot of hours a week whereas Once Upon a Time the claim was that before the end of the 20th century we would only have to do a three-day work week because there wouldn't be much work to go around imagine um yeah so another fear is will almost all the money go to 5 to 10
enormous technology Giants um I actually think this is a more serious worry this seems to be the direction that we're headed in at the moment um I think there's no doubt that modern networks and a concentration of AI Talent tend to encourage this outcome um just but you know essentially this is the modern analog of what happened in the early Decades of the 20th century you know the equivalent then was Transportation networks and it was domination of the new Transportation networks like Railways that led to a few people
dominating the economic system um but what happens there um would be you know essentially comes down to a political and social question so um as I was mentioning before after the Great Depression countes successfully dealt with the monopolistic power of a small number of companies um and with political leadership we could do that again um the problem is that there's not much sign of political leadership right at the moment um but that's um a political problem to solve rather than actually being a technological problem
to solve um so the next problem is should we be afraid of an imminent Singularity IE when machines have artificial general intelligence beyond the human level um in particular um would such an event threaten human survival um so this is um uh concern that is increasingly um explo exploded into the mainstream with discussions of AI existential risk and in quite a few of the discussions that have been leading to the setting up of things like AI safety institutes in the US UK um are motivated by maybe um there
are these worries of out of control artificial intelligence um taking over and deciding to eliminate Humanity so we get these sort of article headlines like pausing AI developments isn't enough we need to shut it all down how Rogue AIS may arise AI Godfather Jeffrey Hinton warns of dangers as he quits Google we must slow down the race to Godlike AI um I don't personally um give these concerns too much credence um and I think there's started to be increasing push back against them um so in the
other direction um franois charal who is the architect of caras sort of argues there does not exist any AI model or technique that could represent an Extinction risk for Humanity not even if you extrapolate capabilities far into the future V scaling laws most arguments boil down to this is a new type of Technology it could happen um Joel Pino who um meta AI leader um refers to existential risk discour is unhinged and points out the flaw of the lot of the utilitarian argumentation that goes along with discussions of
these risks which is um you know if you say the elimination of um humanity is infinitely bad that means you know any any nonzero chance multiplied by Infinity will be bigger than the Badness of anything else that could happen in the world um but that that isn't actually a sensible way to have rational discussion about the outcomes and many people including Tim n jeu have argued that a lot of the well a lot of what the a lot of the outcome of this focus on existential risk and if you're more cynical a lot of
the purpose of this focus of on existential risk is to distract away from the immediate harms that are arising from companies deploying automated systems including their biases worker exploitation copyright violation disinformation growing concentration of power and Regulatory capture by Leading AI companies and that's something that is worth you know thinking about that behind all the discussions of our amazing AIS and all the things we can do with them like get our homework done or generate wonderful images that there are
lots of things underneath about disinformation deception um hallucinations um problems of homogeneity of decision making violation of copyrights and people's creativity lots of carbon emissions um erosion of Rich human practices so we need to be conscious of the sort of present day harms that can come about from AI um and for NLP as well there are various kinds of harms that we've touched on which include generating offensive content generating untruthful content and enabling disinformation so the
disinformation one is an interesting one that if models can reason well about texts can they also be persuasive in communicating incorrect information or opinions to users perhaps there are new possibilities for doing very personalized um misinformation propagation that easily persuades human beings better than traditional methods of political advertising and there's starting to be evidence that that's true it's still being debated in the literature but there's now multiple studies suggesting that humans can be
influenced by disinformation generated by AIS and it seems reasonable to think that we're going to start to see more use of that in political systems and elsewhere which is potentially um quite scary and you know perhaps the worst of it isn't going to be text based it's likely that visual um fakes are going to be even more compelling in political context and um this sort of seems like whether it happens in the US for this election or in other countries in their election that we're likely to see some major
incidents where um AI generated fakes can be seen of having a major impacts on political systems so I sort of think really um what we should be doing is worrying not about existential risks but worrying about what people and organizations with power will use AI to do um that this is a pattern that we've noticed multiple times Al so with social media right in the early days of social media there was the idea that this was meant to lead to new freedoms for people across the globe bringing the positives of free political
um thought and improved human lives in lar measure that isn't what's happened that new technologies get captured by powerful people and organizations who Master the new technological options and Ai and machine learning is being increasingly used um for surveillance and control and we're seeing that around the world at the moment um so my final thought to end with um is a thought about Carl San so when I was young many decades ago um Carl Sean did the series Cosmos on television explaining the Miracles of
the universe and at the time when I was a teenager I loved Cosmos now this was a long time ago um so much more recently there's now a new generation of Cosmos and the book is advertised on the basis of with a new forward by Neil degrass Tyson um I think um K San was a good guy um and he didn't only write Cosmos he wrote a number of other books and another of the books he wrote um was the demon Haunted World um which has a theme that's a little bit um closer um to um some of the things
that connect with um what we're dealing with here um so in that book um he writes I have a for boing of a world in my children's or grandchildren's time when awesome technological powers are in the hands of a very few and no one representing the public interest can even grasp the issues when the people have lost the ability to set their own agendas or knowledgeably question those in Authority when clutching our crystals and nervously Consulting our horoscopes our critical faculties in Decline unable
to distinguish between what feels good and what's true we slide almost without noticing back into Superstition and darkness um I think if you look around the US and many other parts of the world today um this is actually much more the risk um that humanity is facing and why um education which we try to provide at Stanford and other places is an important thing um that should be valued and all the other things that go along with this of having things like open source that supports the broad dissemination of
learning thank you [Applause]